welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
like this every Tuesday I'm Zack Stone
and I'm here to talk to you about super
computers for machine learning called
cloud GPUs you can ask questions at any
time on the platform and we have
Googlers on standby to answer them let's
get started here's a sneak peek at three
generations of our tensor processing
unit systems or TP use that we're going
to be talking about today but before we
get into the details I'd just like to
set a little bit of context about the
tremendous amount of progress in machine
learning there's been over the past
several years to explain why these TP
use are so useful there's a website
called archive where people are
publishing papers and machine learning
out in the open and what you can see
here is a plot of the number of papers
published over time the amazing thing is
this rate is tracking faster than
Moore's Law and we're now up to more
than 50 machine learning papers
published every day there's a tremendous
amount of activity in the field and
among those many papers there have been
tremendous improvements in accuracy on
standard benchmarks such as the image
net image recognition competition you
can see here off to the last the alux
net paper that was the first one to
apply these deep convolutional neural
networks with GPUs to the image net
challenge and then since then there's
been tremendous innovation both in the
network architectures the systems to
train these models all the way up and to
the right here in 2017 and we've even
exceeded these accuracies now but this
isn't just about benchmarks for a
scientific computing these new deep
learning models have also brought about
breakthroughs in real-world applications
such as you can see here in diabetic
retinopathy so researchers at the
medical brain team here at Google had
been trying to diagnose a leading cause
of blindness from taking these images of
the back of the eye and they discovered
in the process of doing so that you can
also get early indications of heart
disease in this entirely passive way
this wasn't previously known and this is
just one small indication of how these
machine learning models are opening up
new app
locations in medicine and elsewhere that
are really going to improve people's
lives
similarly here folks have been
repurposing old cell phones as listening
devices in the rain forest to help catch
signs of illegal logging in the central
Amazon so these applications are just a
sample of many many new ways that
machine learning can be applied now that
we're reaching these high level of
accuracies across many different domains
ranging from image recognition to speech
recognition to machine translation and
more and one thing that I've found
especially exciting is that the same
kinds of mathematical techniques are now
used to achieve state-of-the-art results
across these many different disciplines
when I was in grad school in computer
vision the techniques that we used in
computer vision didn't relate at all to
the techniques that were being used for
state-of-the-art speech recognition at
the time or state of the art machine
translation now even though the models
aren't necessarily the same we're
finding that they're built of the same
building blocks the dense linear algebra
the matrix multiplies and vector
operations that have been put together
in this field called deep learning and
so what that means is you can use some
of the same tools and the same hardware
platforms to solve many different
problems however there's a challenge as
you can see here going back to that case
study of image recognition accuracy
improving over time as you're getting to
higher and higher levels of accuracy
you're also requiring more and more
computation in this case on the x-axis
you're seeing the number of multiply add
operations which is sort of a rough
measure of complexity of the amount of
compute required to run one of these
models but that also corresponds to the
amount of compute that you're required
to train the model and so we're
continuing to move up and to the right
but we're requiring more computation to
do it both to train the model and then
to run that model and make it useful so
how do we address this challenge well we
believe that the answer is specialized
hardware for machine learning such as
these tensor processing unit
here's a brief tour of the history of TP
use at Google this is the first one that
we built that's been deployed in data
center since 2015
this one was focused on inference and
you interacted with one of these
whenever you ran a search it would be
used to rear ank the last several
hundred results to choose those ten blue
links that you get every time you search
on Google it was used in Street View in
Google photos in speech recognition and
across a wide variety of applications
that you interact with every day but
that wasn't enough we moved on after
that to the second generation tensor
processing unit which was built into
these whole systems here you can see a
device that we call the cloud CPU that
you can rent today on the Google cloud
it's in beta there's no waiting no
sign-up you just follow the link gqo
slash cloud TPU and fire up a cloud GPU
following our QuickStart but these
devices aren't just standalone the way
the first DPU was they're actually
designed to be connected together into
these giant super computers called TPU
pods and these will be coming to cloud
later this year both in the the larger
configurations and in smaller slices
that you can use on demand and the nice
thing about the TPU pod is you can apply
even more computation to a single
machine learning problem to train a
model to the accuracy that you desire
faster that helps you really improve
your iteration time because training a
model is sort of like compiling code in
the world that you're used to of
programming line by line you have to do
it over and over again to develop a good
application and at Google i/o we
revealed that we're not just stopping at
TPU v2 we have a TPU v3 which is a whole
new chip built into these whole new
systems that are even larger and more
powerful than the TPU v2 device and pod
so just to give you a quantitative sense
of how fast this field is moving and and
the lengths were going to to achieve
even greater amounts of machine learning
performance you can see that TPU v1 was
able to do 92 tera ops
whereas cloud TPU took that to 180
teraflops you know with 64 gigabytes of
high bandwidth memory per board
going from inference only in the first
generation to supporting training and
inference in the second generation you
stitch all those together and you can do
even more than eleven and a half
petaflop s--
with four terabytes of HBM and now the
third generation pod breaks the barrier
of a hundred petal flops more than 8x
the performance of a TPU v2 pod through
both a new chip and this larger scale
system so we're really committed to
expanding the AI frontier and to sharing
our hardware platforms and the software
we've run on top of them like tensorflow
with all of you through Google Cloud so
I'd like to focus on real-world
performance with the cloud deep use that
you can rent today
now I know that one thing if your
training machine learning models or
running machine learning models
performance is one of the most important
features for you and I just want to
emphasize how important it is to measure
performance carefully we try to
emphasize performance measurements that
are that are involving real data where
you have a retail model that's training
to a specific accuracy and then you're
measuring the complete time to accuracy
or cost to accuracy if you read about
performance out on the internet you
might see people talking about images
per second or steps per second and
that's important but it's not useful if
you're just measuring that in isolation
because it's really important to make
sure that the model that you're
measuring that's processing let's say
lots of images per second will actually
get to the destination you want to go
which is a specific accuracy on a
specific benchmark data set so whenever
you're looking at benchmarks we really
encourage you to look for real-world
data you know not just synthetic data
for time to accuracy and also look for
total cost especially via public clouds
where it's easy to do these apples to
apples comparisons we've also put a lot
of emphasis on making our machine
learning benchmarks reproducible via
open source so you don't just have to
believe the numbers that I'm sharing
today you can run our open source code
on cloud GPUs and measure results
yourself either on standard benchmarks
or then on your own data one benchmark
competition that we think was especially
well-designed was from Stanford it's
called dawn bench and there's a URL here
this competition recently concluded and
they looked at a variety of data sets
including the standard image net
benchmark for image recognition and they
measured both training time and total
cost and they also had other
competitions for inference and we think
that these metrics were really getting
at the kinds of things that US
practitioners care about in your day to
day work
I'm happy to announce that we had the
number one Don Bench entry for image net
training cost and we achieved that with
this ameba net d model and the
interesting thing about am even at D is
the architecture was actually built on a
TPU through an evolutionary process
automatically so instead of designing
this model by hand with countless grad
student hours the way most of those
models that I referenced earlier have
been designed we ran a search process
measuring a population of models and
choosing the ones that performed best on
similar image recognition tasks then
we've open-sourced that final winning
model I'm even at D and you can run it
yourself on the cloud GPU platform today
turns out it trains to the target
accuracy of 93 percent top-five on image
net in just seven and a half hours for
under fifty bucks which we think makes
these kinds of state-of-the-art machine
learning results much more affordable
for everybody there's also a model
called resonant 50 that's often used as
a benchmark to compare different systems
one to the other and so I should just
mention here that our resin at 50
implementation which is also open source
is able to deliver 30 to 50 images a
second with real data which is really
exciting and trained to the similar
final accuracy of 93 percent top 5 which
is not easy to achieve with resin at 50
model that happens in 8.9 hours for 60
dollars and if you want to go even
faster this is the advantage of being
able to scale up into these pods here
you can see our number one Don branch
entry with half of a TPU pod where we
were able to Train in just 30 minutes
and actually if you eliminate the
overhead of checkpointing to measure
your accurate
at every step the the minimum time is
just twenty three point nine minutes to
get to that same 93% accuracy target so
I'm really excited about the fact that
you can develop on one of these cloud
CPUs and then soon you'll be able to
scale up with no code changes just
changing your batch size on to larger
and larger slices of these CPU pods now
I mentioned earlier the number of
archived papers that are getting
published every day and there's real
progress happening there including new
tricks that sometimes make it that
changed the algorithms and make it
possible to achieve your goals even
faster one set of those tricks came from
an organization called fast AI which
published a very strong third place
entry in the dawn bench competition they
showed that if you progressively scale
up the size of your training images
while you're training that can let you
go even faster in the early stages of
your training process and they also came
up with a different more aggressive
learning rate schedule that wasn't
widely known that had been published
previously and they put these together
and they were able to train the rezident
50 model with this modified training
protocol to 93% accuracy much faster
fortunately because all this is
happening out in the open we were able
to reproduce these algorithmic changes
quickly on cloud cpu after the done
bench competition is closed and that
takes our training costs down from 59 to
just $25 even at on demand pricing so we
think it's really fantastic that so many
people are out there experimenting with
different things and that they're
sharing their results in the open so
that you can benefit from them
immediately on cloud GPUs or other
platforms now you might wonder well
what's the next benchmark challenge now
that dawn bench is over
we recommend ml perf which you can find
at ml per org there's a number of
organizations that are coming together
to define an even newer and more
challenging and diverse set of
benchmarks and so this has been
announced recently and there will be
deadlines later this year if you want to
submit your own entries I'd highly
encourage you to do so so as I mentioned
before if you want to experience the
kind of
I'm talking about today on these cloud
TPU devices 180 teraflops you can do so
by visiting the simplest link as juco
slash cloud TPU but you can also follow
these other two links to see our
documentation where we have tutorials
for many of the models that I'll mention
or you can just go straight to github
and read the code yourself for some of
the state of the art models that I
mentioned earlier today now what's it
like to actually use these cloud GPUs I
want to give you more of a sense of how
these things work and what it's like to
work with them so one important point is
that cloud TP use our network-attached
so this is different from other
accelerators you can choose a VM of
whatever size or shape that you want
which I'm showing here in the middle
here the customer off to the left is SSH
tin to that VM you can install whatever
software you want you can attach other
accelerators if you want to you can
choose a custom size and shape and then
you install our machine image that we
provide which has open-source tensorflow
on it with tensorflow 1.8 and then this
vm communicates over the network with a
cloud TPU now this does lay it add one
layer of interaction but we still try to
provide maximum flexibility and control
with this cloud TPU infrastructure and
the nice thing about this network
separation is that cloud TPU can either
be a single device like I was showing
you earlier or it could be a whole slice
of a pod you don't have to worry about
it there are no drivers to install and
you can use your VM which can be small
to drive this enormous supercomputer to
get your training jobs done quickly and
efficiently now as I've mentioned
throughout these cloud TP use today are
programmed with tensorflow
and I'd recommend using tensorflow 1.8
to get our greatest optimizations and
the maximum performance that we're able
to deliver on cloud GPUs now tensorflow
is a really practical and popular
toolkit ever since being open source in
November 2015 it's just really taken off
if you look at these github stars
they're just up and to the right I think
this is now within the top 5 most
popular projects on github overall and
we've seen more than 13 million
downloads of
tensorflow all around the world so this
is really a production-ready framework
that's used in everything from research
labs to applications that you interact
with that have billions of users now
tensorflow is a whole ecosystem and I'm
gonna focus today on the TF data API on
layers estimators and xla because those
are the components that you use to
program these cloud CPUs so estimators
and layers are these high-level deep
learning abstractions for tensorflow
that you don't just have to use on TP
use you can use them on other platforms
and what as well and we're trying to
make it easy for you to shift code back
and forth from one platform to another
so you're not locked in now here's an
example of the kind of model you might
write with layers and estimators this is
a convolutional model and so you can run
this on your your local computer and how
do you change it to make it compatible
with a TPU well in this case you just
have some small changes to make you wrap
the optimizer here as you can see and
then you're using a TPU estimator and
we're working to minimize these changes
over time now one thing I want to say
though is that high-performance
computing is challenging on any platform
and so we've put a lot of effort into
building a set of reference models that
are open-source that you can just use
right away as starting points so you
don't have to do this performance
optimization from scratch yourself in
these many different application domains
so to give you a sense of the reference
models a snapshot that we have today
we've got the kinds of image recognition
models that I've already discussed off
to the left including this
state-of-the-art amoeba net model we've
also got various size of res nets and
inception models of v2 v3 and v4 but
we've also got object detection with
Retina net that helps you find multiple
objects in an image we've got low
resource models like mobile net if you
want to then deploy your model out at
the edge on a phone or a vehicle or some
other device but these CPUs aren't just
limited to image recognition and object
detection they're also useful for
machine translation or language modeling
or even sentiment analysis or question
answering I'll say a little bit more
about that in
and beyond language and text we are
seeing emerging applications on these TP
use in speech recognition but you can
find in the tensor - tensor toolkit I'll
say a bit more about that and if you're
more of a researcher you're interested
in generating images from scratch and
some of these far out applications where
these these machine learning models are
synthesizing new types of imagery and
sound you can do those on TPU too and
we've got a great example of an image
transformer model so let me go through
some of these applications and this
variety of applications in turn so image
classification typically you're focusing
on small crops of images like you're
seeing here and then applying a category
this is useful for everything from photo
sharing to medical imaging object
detection like I mentioned before you
might have a larger image like I'm
showing here off to the right and you
want to detect a bunch of items in it
and classify them and apply labels with
different confidences in this case
Retina net can operate on surprisingly
large images 896 by 896 achieve a near
state-of-the-art result on Cocoa a
standard object recognition data set and
you can get to that level of accuracy in
about six hours for just 40 bucks on one
of the cloud GPUs that you can rent
today I think that's pretty exciting for
democratizing machine learning and
providing a building block for you to
build your own object detection
applications on top of in machine
translation on the WMT data set that
translates English to German we get to a
blue score of 28 point 6 in just over
six hours again for around $40 for
language modeling as you might use for
an application like smart reply where
you're trying to predict what words or
phrases happen next
it cost a little bit more because you
have to train longer to get to the state
of the art but you reach the state of
the art in just 74 hours again for under
500 dollars and this for the latest
hyper parameters I'd recommend following
the short link on screen now that takes
you to the tensor - tensor toolkit which
is built on top of tensor flow and is
moving even faster and really keeping up
with or extending the state of the art
in research for speech recognition which
you can also find in tensor - tensor you
can get to a word error
of 7.9 in just 13 hours for $86 or you
can train longer to get even closer to
the state-of-the-art with a 7.3 percent
or at error rate and this is a really
great starting point for processing
large volumes of audio or training your
robot to listen to your voice commands
or anything else you'd like to do I'd
also like to emphasize that even
techniques that you wouldn't necessarily
think are a good fit for accelerators
like question answering can be
accelerated here's a QA net where you
take in a paragraph of text you know
some region of unstructured text and
you're asked a question that has an
answer in that text and this QA neck
will highlight the fact in this
unstructured blob of text that
corresponds to the answer this is a fast
implementation that one the dawn bench
squad challenged and so there's going to
be an open-source implementation of this
coming soon
now I mentioned image generation earlier
you can see off to the right in these
rows of different categories these
images have actually been synthesized
from scratch using the image transformer
model and using a cloud GPU you can get
to a score of two point nine eight bits
per dimension lower is better in this
case in 30 hours for under $200 I've
also provided a link to the paper here
if you're interested in learning more so
I've mentioned this variety of reference
models in there more coming all the time
I'd really encourage you even though
it's tempting to take some older code
and try and port it to the TPU I'd
really recommend starting with one of
these reference models to experience the
full performance of the platform right
away and maybe even reach higher
accuracy since these models are so close
to the state of the art they're
high-performance they're open-source
they're cutting-edge we continuously
test them for performance and accuracy
even as all the versions of underlying
software are evolving rapidly and they
really let you get up and running
quickly and then it's your code it's
open source you can modify it as you
need and train and run on your own data
so I want to emphasize though that you
don't just have to use these reference
models you can build models from scratch
using layers and estimators and the TF
data API and there's lots of detailed
technical advice in this troubleshooting
guide and
also in our performance guide and our
documentation of how tools but we're
really trying to do the hardest work for
you via our reference models so
definitely start there today just to
give you one quick sense of why high
performance computing can be so hard
when you're using previous accelerators
that may not have been as fast it's easy
to overlap your input processing with
your training and so then you're fully
utilizing your accelerators which are
often the most expensive part of the
system but now when the accelerators get
faster suddenly your bottlenecked on the
input processing and your accelerators
are idle waiting for data it's quite
challenging to build these balance
systems that can keep the fastest
accelerators supplied with data all the
time and so that's really what we're
trying to do with our TPU supercomputers
and also with all these software layers
that we build on top fortunately if you
are performance tuning one of these
models we've got these great tools that
are integrated with tensor board and
available for cloud CPUs the cloud TPU
profiler lets you actually get detailed
up buy off statistics about how your
models are performing and where they're
bottlenecked and this is a really
amazing tool to let you optimize your
own models and get them running you know
training at full potential we even try
to give you high-level advice I don't
know if you can read it here in red but
this is telling you that your program is
not input bounded so keep working on
your step time we're really trying to
provide higher and higher level guidance
as you're optimizing these models on the
TPU so let me just say for a moment you
know why we recommend doing machine
learning in the cloud how that's
providing advantages to you even if
you're used to working under your desk
or an on-premise data center google
cloud provides top-notch infrastructure
and you can mix and match whatever
components that you need you can
provision quickly you can scale up and
then you can scale back down as your
needs change and really burst to take
advantage of teraflops or even petaflop
of machine learning compute we've also
got a variety of different accelerators
we've got the best of CPUs GPUs TP use
you can mix and match those together to
get the right mix for each workload
that's interesting to you
we've got fantastic security world-class
security and powerful tools for data
access control and controlling the way
that it's being used and most
importantly we let you reduce your
capital expenditure instead of having to
place orders for Hardware wait for
months deploy them change the cooling
and power in your data centers to
support these powerful accelerators you
can just use our on-demand pricing to
pay only for what you need which we find
to be much more economical especially
when your workloads are unpredictable
just to give you two examples of
customers who are using cloud TPS today
both to Sigma and lyft have found it
really convenient to be able to move to
the cloud take models that they already
had in some cases and accelerate them or
take our reference models and use them
to achieve new results on their own
internal data sets now I'll give you
just a brief glimpse under the hood to
give you a little bit more detail on how
these cloud GPUs are able to achieve
such amazing performance now I mentioned
before that each cloud CPU delivers a
hundred and eighty teraflops of
computation with 64 gigabytes of memory
and it's actually got four chips one
under each of those heat sinks and so
here in just a minute I'm gonna focus on
one of those chips but first let me
explain that the cloud TPU is connected
to a host behind the scenes via PCI so
you get you get the benefit of both this
host where some operations can be placed
and then ideally as much of the
computation as possible is placed on the
accelerator so let's zoom in on one of
these GPUs so the cloud TPU chip is
divided into two cores as you can see
here the chip as a whole has 16
gigabytes of HBM split between the cores
and each core delivers 22 and a half
teraflops and consists of a scalar unit
a vector unit and especially this matrix
unit which is really special and and
uniquely suited for the demands of
high-performance machine learning now
focusing on this matrix unit it's
actually a 128 by 128 systolic array now
systolic arrays are this old idea in
chip architecture but they're newly
relevant now that we have these deep
learning models
that have many many layers and consists
of many matrix operations often on these
gigantic matrices one important fact
about our matrix unit is that we're
actually using a different
floating-point format be float16
in the multiplies even though we're
doing float32 accumulate and that turns
out to be a great floating-point format
for machine learning it's almost a
drop-in replacement for float32 and yet
it lets us pack even more compute into
the same amount of silicon area so let
me tell you just a little bit more about
B float16
so you may be used to programming in
float32 that's what most people use
today for machine learning models and
here's how that that those 32 bits are
distributed between the exponent and the
mantissa now I Triple E floats in chops
both of those down so you have a much
reduced exponent and a much reduced
mantissa B float16 by contrast actually
uses a lot more bits for the exponent
which lets us represent numbers that
still have this full range but you lose
a little bit of detail in fine
distinctions between numbers turns out
for all of these state-of-the-art deep
learning models those fine distinctions
don't matter but the range matters a lot
and so you get a much simpler user
experience working with B float16
then you do having to worry about F P 16
where you've got to think carefully
about whether the numbers are in the
right range is everywhere throughout
your model and there are complicated
techniques that you have to apply on a
model by model basis to avoid your
numbers exploding or under flowing or
all sorts of numerical problems we
reduce those problems a lot by working
with B float16 on the cloud GPU so now
here I just want to show you a three by
three toy example to represent this 128
by 128 systolic array to give you a
sense of how as input data is streaming
through there can be a lot of reuse of
inter intermediate computations inside
the systolic array which gives this
fantastic throughput for these large
matrix operations now I just want to
look ahead briefly to give you a sense
of where we think the field is going and
why these cloud GPUs and TPU pods are so
well-suited to help support the future
machine learning products and research
now these cloud TPU pods enable you to
train with very large batch sizes which
you might wonder well how does the
scaling go you know as you as you go
beyond a single device fortunately we've
got this proprietary network that
connects all these devices together in
this mesh and we've been able to show
near perfect linear scaling out all the
way to the full-scale pod as you can see
here as the number of devices increases
to 64 which is the full set in the in
the TPU v2 pod
now I mentioned large batches one other
issue you have to wonder about when
you're dealing with large batch training
is whether you can still make efficient
progress towards the ultimate goal
previously as people increase the batch
size at some point you would find that
you wouldn't reach the final accuracy
that you were expecting and so there was
sort of a mathematical limit and how
large you could make the batch size
before it was no longer efficient or
useful to do so but there's been a lot
of progress on this recently and there's
still very active research and what I'm
showing here is that a model that might
take you know and that that sort of
golden curve you know many hours on a
single board to get to this 76 percent
accuracy as you scale up within the pod
just increasing the batch size not
changing the code you can achieve that
same accuracy in shorter and shorter
wall clock times which really lets you
iterate faster because remember this is
like compiling your code right you need
to compile your code many times to
iterate and explore and sometimes if
you're doing something like hyper
parameter tuning or neural architecture
search you want to train hundreds or
even thousands of different models and
on these pods you can really pull it
pull that time in to get to the same
accuracy and iterate much more quickly
and make faster progress now here's just
a glimpse of our future roadmap I
mentioned the TPU v3 pod that we
announced at Google i/o and here's the
full system with these eight racks and
the whole pod as I mentioned is more
than eight times more powerful than the
TPU pod and actually to get to this
level of performance we brought liquid
cooling into our
data centers for the first time as you
can see here on one of the boards that
makes up that gigantic TPU V 3 pod so
we're really excited about continuing to
expand the frontier of machine learning
you can get started with cloud GPUs
today there's no waiting there's no sign
up there's no need to to make a quota
request every GCP project can start a
cloud GPU today and you can follow just
the link at the bottom the gqo slash
cloud TPU link to get started or one of
these other links to peruse the code of
our open source reference models or jump
straight to our documentation with that
i'd like to invite you to stay tuned for
live Q&A we'll be back in less than a
minute
you
hi everyone I'm back to answer your
questions about cloud GPUs so one
question here is you know I filed a
quota request and haven't heard back yet
when will I get a chance to try cloud
GPUs the good news is as of recently you
no longer need to file a quota request
cloud TPU quota is available to everyone
so you can just go to Google cloud today
and you should find quota for at least
two cloud GPUs possibly more and you can
start one up right now in the US central
region let's see there's another
question here asking about the
performance of TP use vs. GPUs or other
platforms now as I mentioned earlier one
thing that we really recommend is that
you perform your own benchmark
measurements on the workloads that
matter to you
using ideally our reference models that
give you this great starting point but
in in any case we really emphasize that
you should benchmark with realistic
training data so you're measuring the
actual accuracy along the way not just
the samples per second and think about
the total time that it takes to get to
an accuracy if you're measuring training
or the throughput if you're measuring
inference and also the total cost on
public clouds or you know if you're
working on premise the whole capex and
OPEX to run the machines and maintain
them
to get a complete picture of how to
compare one platform to another if you
want to look at you know GPUs and GPU
specifically one of our customers Rhys
ml has published a series of blog posts
where they've looked at TPU and GPU
performance quite carefully you can also
look at the Stanford dawn bench results
let's see where can I access these
reference models so in the tensorflow
github repository at github calm slash
tensorflow
there's a directory slash TPU and a lot
of our reference models are in there as
I mentioned during the talk though there
are some of these that are also in a
different repository which is called
tensor two tensor where the two is a
numeral and it's all one word and so
keep an eye on our reference repository
in github and then also take a look at
the tensor two tensor library for the
real cutting edge of these sequence to
sequence models
this is a great question can I do
inference on TPS or only training TP you
support both training and inference at
the moment our software stack is
continuing to mature and I'd really
recommend training and batch inference
over time as we continue to optimize the
software stack TP you should be great
for low latency inference - but I would
wait just a little bit longer before
diving into that and now somebody's
asking well wait this is the second
generation of TP users their third
generation and so as I mentioned through
the talk we revealed the third
generation TPU at Google i/o it's liquid
cooled we assemble them it's a whole new
chip in a whole new system that we
assemble into much larger pods that
deliver more than a hundred peda flops
of compute collectively so we're pushing
the frontier forward as far as we can to
to enable us to Train even larger and
more powerful and accurate machine
learning models that will then you know
benefit all the users of Google products
through all our different applications
let's see if there are any other
questions here great so one thing one
other thing that you might wonder about
is how to do sort of interactive
development with these cloud CPUs and
one thing that I'd recommend would be
you know do as much as you can with
layers and estimators and the data sets
API on a cloud TPU before you think
about scaling up into a slice of a pod
so the the experience that we're really
trying to build towards is one where you
can you know inexpensively treat one of
these cloud GPUs as your personal
supercomputer in the cloud that you can
just sit on instead of having to worry
about a machine under your desk you just
log into the cloud and pay only for what
you're using as you do your development
and then when you're really ready to
scale up just by changing the batch size
suddenly you're able to transform you
know days in two hours or hours into
minutes and get a lot more done in a
day than you used to be able to do in a
week so we're building a whole new
paradigm for machine learning you know
research development and production here
with cloud GPUs and we invite all of you
to join us on this journey and try out
cloud TP use today thanks very much
stay tuned for the next session which is
make your applications fast and reliable
with the stack driver API thanks again
you